vous avez un point commun avec lino
c'est le vélo la faille croient ils
croient qu'ils la banque à marie-noëlle
vélo l'essai mais le nom il fait du vélo
il fait du vélo comme un tracteur fait
ils disent ils se déplacent à bicyclette
toi bicyclette et vélo ce pan de toit en
chaume à vélo ses 107 av l'autre court
jamais compétition des cyclades ya un
feu rouge une sonnette à un truc que non
l'ailier s'est plaint lino fait de la
bicyclette mais il avait loué à saissac
et paradoxal parce qu'il fait de la
bicyclette sur un vélo c'est l'accès
compliqué car il a un vélo de course
indiscutablement je crois que ces mêmes
louison pas mais qu'il l'a aiguillé là
dessus en riant voyez la référence pour
donc il a apparemment les signes
extérieurs d'un coureur à dire qu'il a
un vélo de course mais le coût de 13 ans
alors lâché et est joué non j'aime mieux
comparé d'autres sur wii